oui
[Musique]
j'ai aussi medinski bonjour nous sommes
heureux de vous voir parmi les invités
d'ayrté voici merci
commençons par le sujet suivant l'année
2021 touche à sa fin il y a trente ans
l'union soviétique s'est effondré nous
aurions bien sûr beaucoup de sujets à
aborder
on restait en calèche des événements de
la seconde guerre mondiale rapporte
quant à la
voilà par quoi j'aimerais commencer ça
si je ne m'abuse vous avez travaillé
comme correspondant du journal russia et
avait assisté à de nombreux événements
quel âge aviez-vous à cette époque un
peu plus de 20 ans et sa
1991 j'avais 20 heures non les jeunes
ceux qui ont 21 ans aujourd'hui ne
connaissent probablement pas clairement
ces événements les générations plus
âgées s'en souvient beaucoup mieux
comment avez vous perçu ces événements à
l'époque est votre vision at elle changé
depuis j'étais parmi les partisans de la
démocratie la rédaction du journal
russia se trouvait à la maison blanche
nous avons passé deux nuits inoubliables
à la rédaction à la maison blanche
on a informé on inventait parfois des
nouvelles ont imprimé des tracts on
était au centre de presse du ministère
des affaires étrangères lors de la
célèbre conférence de presse du comité
d'état pour l'état d'urgence est un
espion se préparer à l'assaut il y avait
des kalachnikov au bureau je ne sais pas
s'ils étaient chargés ou non mais il y
en avait je connais bien sûr changé
plusieurs fois d'opinion sur ces
événements comme tout le monde s'en
doute mais à ce moment là il y avait
bien sûr une sorte d'euphorie
démocratique a dit enthousiaste
et comme largo allez on vous dit
plusieurs fois en tête pourriez-vous
déterminer quand 8,2 contre l'avant
dernière est la dernière il intéresse
tout le monde aujourd'hui trente ans
plus tard
à une personne qui n'a pas une seule
fois en 30 ans changer de point de vue
sur certains processus et événement
mérite certainement une attention et un
respect particulier
je ne suis pas comme ça d'un show et
nous vivons nous évoluions il y a donc
différents avis diamétralement opposées
sur les événements de cette époque
soutien radicale aux défenseurs de la
maison blanche il ya helsinn ou aux
démocrates jusqu'au sympathie pour le
comité d'état d'urgence que tu
vas t'en ici dans ce spectre dans cette
perspective nous nous demandons tous les
pays tout entier qu'elle était la
meilleure option aurait-il pu se passer
yep c'est moi tu organises nous n'en
savons rien l'histoire ne nous a pas
donné le choix il est arrivé ce qui est
arrivé
malheureusement cela a conduit à des
conséquences irréversibles auxquelles
nous n'avions pas pensé
et probablement si seulement j'avais pu
imaginer à l'époque en août 91 à quoi
aboutir et ces événements c'est encore
un stade seulement se terminerait cet
enthousiasme joyeux dans la lutte contre
le monopole du parti communiste et la
censure on apprenait qu'un point mais
personne ne pensait que cela aboutirait
à l'effondrement d'un grand pays sources
à quoi je sers tenir à ce programme oui
la dîmière poutine qualifie cela très
ouvertement ces derniers temps de
tragédie et d'effondrement de la russie
story est allé jusqu'à pas savoir selon
les sondages aujourd'hui la plupart des
russes principalement ceux qui ont vécu
sous l'union soviétique regrette que
cela se soit produit comme au litre
d'eau à des tiers non il ya 30 ans
l'attitude était différente qu'est ce
qui a provoqué selon vous ce changement
d'opinion
je ne crois pas que l'attitude était
différente c'est juste que personne
n'avait pensé ou cela mènerait il n'y
avait pas vraiment en masse de volonté
sincère de voir l'urss être dissoute
chef sans prendre en compte une partie
de la société dans les pays baltes mais
il ne s'agit que d'une partie et aussi
peut-être le comportement de
l'intelligencia démocratique à moscou et
à saint pétersbourg qui avait également
tendance à se faire des illusions c'est
tout
sur tous les autres plans nous
n'imaginions tout simplement pas congé
très le bébé avec l'eau du bain
princesses et les chips drobo
je ne pouvions pas nous figurer qu'en
luttant pour l'en nous perdrions l'autre
c'est ça la question personne ne voulait
l'effondrement du pays personne ne
voulait qu'un visa soit nécessaire pour
se rendre à yuma là qu'on ne puisse ne
pas y aller du tout comme aujourd'hui
personne ne voulait de conflit civil ou
une vraie guerre en asie centrale si
dieu merci a été surmontée d'une manière
ou d'une autre
nick tonnes y demande en temps je t
embrasse moi j'attaque plus personne ne
voulait une guerre dans le caucase
personne ne pensait qu'une situation
aussi folle avec l'ukraine d'où je viens
ce soit possible personne ne pensait que
les troupes de l'otan seraient déployées
à quelques kilomètres des frontières de
notre pays comme tout simplement à la
frontière entre
mille tonnes dont personne ne pensait
que ce pays qui a été construit pendant
des siècles par nos ancêtres seraient en
fait miraculeusement préservée dans ses
frontières d'il ya des siècles
mais quand survivent par miracle au lieu
de partir en morceaux
sur toute la zone d'influencé de l'urss
et l'union soviétique en plus du fait
qu'elle représentait en sixième des
terres émergées et 300 millions
d'habitants avait une énorme zone d'
influence et des alliés pas seulement en
europe de l'est mais aussi en asie en
afrique en amérique par tout ce à quoi
tout cela se fragmente moins bonne
attaque nous étions vous le savez un
empire à l'envers si l'empiré
britannique au sommet de sa puissance
s'étendait sur un cinquième des terres
émergées sur lesquels le soleil ne se
couchait jamais recensée tu es en empire
qui drainait des ressources l'urss était
un empire inversée qui au nom de
certains objectifs politiques et
idéologiques scène et moi je veux être
éphémère peut être fantaisiste nombre
inutilement humaniste ou naïfs qui vous
met dans ses intérêts il subventionner
la moitié du monde
je trouve que tout cela cessera
d'exister qui a dit que dans ce pays les
gens ont commencé à vivre mieux après
cela je ne sais plus nous étions donc
assez naïf monde antique
dont je te cite chasse le fait que la
plupart des gens regrette maintenant le
démantèlement de l'urss ne signifie pas
qu'ils veulent restaurer le système
socialiste avec tous ces inconvénients
non ils veulent juste comme je lé déjà
évoqué dans notre conversation
embarqué dans un train le soir pour se
rendre aux pays baltes se rendre
librement chez leurs parents et amis en
ukraine ils ont envie de cet étonnant
climat de fraternité et de compréhension
mutuelle qui cimentait toutes nos
républiques alliés j'ai correspondu avec
un officier vietnamiens quand j'étais
écolier il servait au sein de l'armée
populaire de libération du vietnam et
collectionner des timbres vie où ils
m'ont envoyé des timbres il a même
appris le russe pour m'écrire quelque
chose et moi je lui ai envoyé d'éteindre
soviétique j'ai du mal à imaginer
comment cela se fait aujourd'hui comme
ça qu'il y ait facebook mais on éprouve
plus de telles émotions messieurs
medinski j'aimerais revenir à votre
évaluation des événements et obtenir des
réponses concrètes si possible et vous
d'accord avec vladimir poutine que c'est
tout de même une tragédie vous avez
énoncés et beaucoup de points négatifs y
compris que ça a été la désintégration
de la russe historique littéralement
c'est la plus grande catastrophe
géopolitique du 20e siècle et pour notre
pays c'est tout simplement la plus
grande catastrophe géopolitique depuis
de nombreux siècles parce l'avenir
nos gars t'as laitiers
groupe de chahrazad un grand pas en
arrière pour notre puissance
l'évaluation du président l ce n'est pas
parce que je suis son conseiller que je
suis d'accord avec elle mais parce que
99% des citoyens de notre pays j'en suis
certain partage cet avis dans mon jeu
trente ans plus tard sentez-vous en
parlant des peuples des anciennes
républiques soviétiques je comprends
qu'ils sont tous différents mais tout de
même certaines ont peut-être tendance à
se rapprocher plus particulièrement de
nous peut-être que ce processus a été
enclenché ou qu'au contraire tout a pris
une direction différente
sur certains veulent se rapprocher de
nous et d'autres ont déjà évolué dans de
nouvelles réalités et n'ont aucune idée
de comment c'était avant beaucoup ne
connaissent déjà plus la langue russe
quand nous allons dans nos républiques
soeurs comme on les appelle nous
constatons avec surprise et parfois même
avec le sentiment que nous devons parler
anglais avec les jeunes dans un café ce
qui nous gêne
parce qu'ils n'ont pas appris le russe
ils ne le connaissent pas mais ceux qui
savent ce qu'ils se souviennent c'est
vrai on envie de se rapprocher de nous
je le répète ce n'est pas une envie de
socialisme ce n'est pas une envie de
censure ou de difficultés liées à
l'autorisation d'aller à l'étranger
tiens c'est une aspiration envers cette
idée humaniste qui unit les gens et qui
permettait de fait peut maintenir la
paix et de lier des gens de diverses
nationalités
mix avare en tant que tel le problème du
nationalisme n'existait pas du tout à la
fin de l'urss ça se passe à washington
on avait tout simplement pas ce problème
personne ne s'intéressait à votre
nationalité
pour ce qui est des blagues on pouvait
rire dans chaque république parce qu'il
y avait différentes histoires drôles
mais tout de même tout cela est apparu
très rapidement à un moment donné
les mauvaises choses apparaissent
rapidement peu d'efforts sont
nécessaires pour provoquer le mal est
bien c'est que c'était là peut-être que
c'est à cacher quelque part oui
certainement le diable existe bel et
bien
parlons du mémorial des nageurs vous
avez directement pris part à sa
construction
pourquoi était si important pour vous
pourriez vous nous en dire un peu plus
sur l'idée en elle-même bien ça n'était
pas seulement important pour moi de
manière générale il nous a toujours
semblé que c'était une page
malheureusement peu connue de la seconde
guerre mondiale et qui méritaient une
attention particulière une commémoration
spéciale et en hommage aux héros qui se
sont battus jusqu'à la mort pour
défendre notre pays chen ajoutant comme
cet enchaînement de bataille ne s'est
pas terminée par une victoire triomphale
on en parle peu
ce n'est pas la bataille de stalingrad
ni le saillant de course que ni la
bataille de berlin ni l'opération back
gration
c'est une sorte de verdun russe une
saignée pour les deux côtés qui a duré
plusieurs mois
comme toujours ça a été plus ou moins un
hasard d'abord les anciens combattants
se sont adressés à l'association
d'histoire militaire russe avec une
proposition visant à perpétuer cette
mémoire d'un jeune au fil des ans
l'association d'histoire militaire
avec les beaux isco vicky du mouvement
rossia jours parce qu'on va expédier des
bénévoles qui cherchent les restes de
soldats soviétiques sur les lieux des
combats et avec le ministère de la
défense a organisé une expédition de
recherche annuel des classes nous avons
déterré des milliers et des milliers de
personnes dans des fosses communes sans
nom skyways essayant d'identifier les
restes nous les avons inhumé
conformément aux lois humaines et
militaires c'est un travail sans fin
parce qu'il y à des ossements partout la
terre on est parsemé
partant on ashley nous avons trouvé une
petite maison en bois elles subsistent
encore ce que est extraordinaire c'est
le seul endroit où staline s'est rendu
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale quand
il est allé au front
c'était l'été de l'année 1943 je crois
et c'est là où il a tenu une réunion
avec le commandant du front de kalinine
andrei irait même qu est cette maison a
été préservé nous l'avons restaurer
l'association d'histoire militaire ya
créé un petit musée il y a beaucoup
d'objets liés ou commandant suprême
jusqu'aux meubles aux effets personnels
il y a même un lit sur lequel il n'a pas
dormi car la réunion a duré toute la
nuit
nous avons trouvé des gens qui étaient
les gardiens de ce musée à l'époque il y
avait d'abord un petit musée dans les
premières années d'après-guerre tuées
après le 20ème congrès du parti il a été
fermé l'enseigne a été arraché et on l'a
également trouvé dans le sous sol où
elle était à moitié pourri pour sky news
nous avons reconstruit ce musée
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment un lieu de
pèlerinage pour les touristes y battant
dallas
et puis un groupe d'initiative s'est
formé dirigé par grigori rap ôta qui
était alors secrétaire général de
l'union de la russie et de la
biélorussie
montoise une économie où son père avait
participé au combat après deux chefs et
admire a curieusement survécu et ce
monument a été érigé presque entièrement
grâce aux dons publics
il y a une certaine contribution
budgétaire de l'union de la russie et de
la biélorussie
ce qui est aussi très important en mai
le reste n'a rien à voir avec le budget
fédéral c'est de l'argent des
contribuables ce monument est très
respectée deux millions de personnes
l'ont déjà visité pas choix mais un peu
plus d'un an s'est écoulé depuis son
inauguration
il y a un petit pavillon donc on peut
facilement compter le nombre de types
gestionnaire c'est vraiment beaucoup
c'était étonnant et pourquoi les gens
s'y rendent thil est sis au fait que
staline y soit allé que pouvez vous
répondre
d'ailleurs aux personnes qui disent
pourquoi avons nous besoin d'un musée
concernant staline et qui sont de fait
opposés à cette idée je n'ai pas au
musée au sujet de staline c'est juste
qu'il est connu au sein du peuple comme
la maison de staline
ou dix huitième et c'est vraiment un
endroit incroyable je pense que dans
n'importe quel pays jamais un tel
endroit ne serait tombé dans l'oubli
si un tel monument exister
cette maison n'est pas à proximité du
mémorial de relief c'est à 10 minutes en
voiture
mais oui il y un buste de staline encore
une fois cela a été réalisé grâce aux
efforts du peuple pas à ceux du
ministère de la culture dont j'étais
ministre à l'époque est libre elle parce
que chez nous tout ce qui concerne le
nom de staline suscite une réaction
malsaine c'est en tort
il faut séparer le bon grain de l'ivraie
lorsque nous parlons de la répression
nous devons dire la vérité au sujet de
la répression
quand on parle de la seconde guerre
mondiale on doit dire la vérité sur la
seconde guerre mondiale
il ne faut pas tout mettre dans le même
temps sinon apparaissent dans les têtes
des jeunes des bêtises toutes ces idées
comme on a gagné la guerre malgré
staline et juke offre comme s'ils jouent
comme se réveiller le matin en se
demandant quelle nouvelle mauvaise
opération il fallait planifié pour tuer
le plus de soldats soviétiques possible
accession c'est insupportable de voir
cela
l'union pourquoi les gens seront-ils
parce que c'est la mémoire c'était le
bon endroit semble-t-il et le complexe a
été bien conçu c'est un grand honneur
pour nous que le président russe avec la
participation du président biélorusse
halle est inauguré en personne il a
prononcé beaucoup de mots inoubliable
ces derniers temps on entend parler y
compris au niveau des autorités que nous
luttons contre la réécriture de
l'histoire
mais dans les conditions de la vraie
guerre de l'information qui a lieu comme
beaucoup estiment de l'imposition de la
méfiance à l'égard de la rue des
initiatives venant de moscou en
particulier dans ce domaine là dans
quelle mesure est-il possible de vaincre
la réécriture de l'histoire non pas à
l'intérieur du pays mais à l'extérieur
remonte et istres année
il faut dire la vérité il est impossible
de vaincre cela l'histoire a été
réécrite à toutes les époques je pense
depuis le temps des pharaons égyptiens
vinicole dans la rome antique il existe
une législation sur l'oubli des
nouvelles autorités est éliminé de
vastes période de l'histoire interdisait
de mentionner les noms des précédents
dirigeants pharmaciens boys gagnent
effacer les inscriptions gravées sur des
stèles en pierre couper les têtes des
statuts pour les remplacer par les têtes
d'autres empereur tribe ans et consuls
donc ça a toujours été comme ça il
suffit de dire la vérité et d'essayer de
préserver cette vérité
l'humanité a parcouru un long chemin et
nous espérons qu'elle apprend au fur et
à mesure à tirer des conclusions de son
histoire
kaki si cette vérité n'est pas entendu
ou s'ils ne veulent pas l'entendre grand
qu il faut donc parler plus fort vous
êtes là pour ça il y a les médias pour
faire ça la vérité se fraiera toujours
un passage
on vient d'évoquer la répression pendant
des décennies nous avons tout le temps
commis les mêmes erreurs vous savez
pendant des décennies nous n'avons pas
mentionné le nom de staline dans un
contexte de positif qu'en tant que
commandant suprême
il a pourtant assumé l'entière
responsabilité de l'organisation de la
défense du pays et malgré de nombreuses
erreurs que beaucoup auraient commises à
sa place nous avons gagné mais on a
évité de le mentionner midi n'est ce pas
la même chose que lorsque l'on effacé
ses adversaires de photographies ou
lorsqu on arrachait des pages des
manuels concernant des gens qui avaient
été réprimées quand qu'on va le voir les
strings c'est la même chose c'est la
même chose mais inversés options dont
j'aimerais tant que
l'histoire doit être représenté dans
toute sa complexité dans tous ses
aspects avec ces pages heureuse et ces
pages sombres ce n'est que comme cela
qu'on peut en tirer des leçons et cian
healy a de nos jours le programme les
chefs d'armée oublié à ce sujet il ya
beaucoup d'éminents chefs militaires et
agents du renseignement dans notre pays
qui pour diverses raisons en tout
simplement été rayés de la mémoire
historique
ils ont bien sûr surtout été réprimé à
la veille de la guerre
c'est le destin n'avait pas été aussi
cruel envers eux oui une semaine il
aurait pu devenir maréchaux de la
victoire en juin 1945 mais au lieu de
cela mes pages mentionnant leur nom ont
été arrachés des manuels scolaires il ne
reste rien qu'en pas de plaque
commémorative sa de rue pas de bus très
classe et ils ont énormément contribué
au renforcement des capacités défensives
de notre pays à la construction de
l'armée rouge juste avant la guerre idem
pour les agents de renseignement
certains d'entre eux ont été oubliés
parce qu'ils sont morts pendant les
premiers jours de la guerre ils ne sont
donc pas considérés comme héros ils sont
morts à l'été 1941 et c'est tout
certains sont morts dans d'autres
circonstances il en va d'ailleurs de
même pour les événements
révolutionnaires
nous souvenons nous de ces officiers
généraux illustre de l'armée impériale
qui ont été victimes de la révolution de
février et qui ont été mises en pièces
écrasé dans la neige par des marins ivre
à cronstadt dans la foux de joie à
l'idée de liberté de démocratie
victorieuse
savez bien on les a oubliés
nous découvrons aujourd'hui c'est non
c'est un programme commun de
l'association d'histoire militaire
c'est notre propre travail avec le
soutien du service des renseignements
extérieurs et du ministère de la défense
nous veillons à ce que la réputation de
ces gens ne soient vraiment pas entachée
par quoi que ce soit et qu'il soit
vraiment considérer pour leur grand
mérite pour la patrie sur leur lieu de
service pas mais ce trou sur leur lieu
de naissance nous installons des plaques
commémoratives sur les écoles installons
des bus nous monde et rue en leur
honneur
70-80 parfois 100 ans se sont écoulés
depuis mai nous replaçons ces personnes
méritantes dans notre mémoire historique
parce que la vie avait été injuste
envers il y a un devoir de mémoire nous
devons honorer la mémoire de ces gens
parce qu'ils ont sacrifié leur vie pour
le pays la vérité ressort toujours tôt
ou tard notre tâche est de faire en
sorte que cela se produise tout est de
ne pas oublier cette vérité
il ya de nos jours un sujet très
concrets pour les jeunes les forces de
l'ordre depuis déjà un certain temps
s'intéresse à des rappeurs
aujourd'hui tout le monde parle de
morgenstern ce qui est curieux c'est une
nouvelle étape de la procédure a été
entamée après ses propos sur le 9 mai la
fête de la victoire pour résumer il a
dit que de nouvelles victoires étaient
nécessaires vous ne pouviez pas dépenser
autant d'argent pour les célébrations
ils m'ont pourriez vous commenter cela
à quel point sont dangereux de tels
propos étant donné qu'il est
effectivement très populaire
peut-on détruire sa carrière à cause de
tels propos
donc si remis les biens en raison de son
niveau d'intelligence ce très jeune
homme ne s'est peut-être pas exprimé de
manière très sensée
mais il faut noter que cela reflète le
point de vue dans certain nombre de
personnes regardent amitié
par conséquent si ce n'est pas une
raison pour ruiner la carrière de
quelqu'un ou de le déranger mais il y as
d'autres questions sérieuses la
propagande en faveur de la drogue par
exemple on faisait cela il est
nécessaire d'appliquer des mesures
strictes car les rappeurs les youtuber
et autres sons populaire parmi les
jeunes dont le cerveau n'est pas
entièrement formés
il est stupéfiant en particulier la
drogue dure sont en mal absolu
dans ce cas il faut avoir recours à tous
les moyens nécessaires
mais en fin de compte ils chantent à ce
sujet depuis des années pourquoi tous
remarqué cela après certains propos sur
le jour de la victoire
ce n'est aucunement lié je crois que le
jour de la victoire n'a absolument rien
à voir avec cela mais il faut lutter
contre la drogue de la manière la plus
dure y compris contre toutes les formes
de propagande concernant les stupéfiants
surtout quand il s'agit d'informations
destinées aux jeunes
il ya peu j'ai assisté à la réunion du
club de discussion valdaï
le président vladimir poutine a
longuement parlé des défis qui se posent
à l'humanité à présenter ses thèses pour
un nouvel ordre mondial il ya eu
beaucoup de commentaires
quelqu'un a déclaré qu'il avait même
formulé une nouvelle idéologie russe
êtes vous d'accord avec cela
lorsque de telles thèses sont exprimés
peut-on dire que nous dans ce cas en la
personne du président regardons vers
l'avenir et que nous ne nous opposons
pas la civilisation occidentale
le président a parlé de conservatisme
éclairé en tant que moyen pour
l'humanité de préserver le meilleur de
ce que notre culture et notre
civilisation ont créé au cours du
dernier millénaire
le président a expliqué que le
patriotisme au sens classique du terme
était la meilleure idéologie nationale
mais qu'est ce que le patriotisme
le patriotisme provient du mot pater ce
qui signifie perdre et le patriotisme
c'est l'amour de la patrie challes
encore ce qu'on sait l'amour pour la
terre deiber et au sens large c'est
l'amour des pères de votre famille
est il possible de trouver une meilleure
idéologie que l'amour pour sa famille
pour ses parents pour ses ancêtres pour
la terre sur laquelle on a grandi et
qu'on a cultivé et le désir de préserver
de défendre au sens étroit comme large
du mot cette terre et sa famille
c'est vraiment la meilleure idéologie
qui puisse être reproché canal il fauche
qui n'a écrit des vers sur l'amour pour
les cercueils paternel vous vous
souvenez
graves
sur eux reposent depuis des siècles par
la volonté de dieu lui-même
l'indépendance de l'homme est le gage de
sa grandeur niché au
oui vous ne pouvez pas dire mieux cet
amour pour son foyers natals pour les
cercueils paternel et probablement
l'idéologie officielle la plus correcte
pour l'instant du moins c'est certain
la dîmière medinski merci beaucoup pour
cette conversation surtout dans un
endroit aussi intéressant vous êtes le
bienvenu
venez nous rendre visite plus souvent
nous avons comme vous le voyez beaucoup
de livres intéressants sur l'histoire de
la russie
[Musique]